hello and welcome to this video playing
poor deed Ike maybe could be anything in
terms of pronunciation okay let's stick
and go for ten let's see what is going
to do they often play their standard set
up against the time on off if they play
Bishop III stuff let's say against the
night off it will often be their weapon
of choice here as well so let's see what
he's doing starting a deep calculation
that's a good one
Oh
not what I expected f4 hmm if you want
to play f4 you do it immediately okay I
was successful with an early age five
who kissed in g3 line in an earlier game
maybe I can irritate him here a little
bit aged three is somewhat annoying I
mean also the capture is something to
pay attention to
I just develops my development is slow
it definitely is
hmm they're mad f6s cottage five
I think I was a little bit good to
create a fear for my own good
Wow that's not great shouldn't afraid
the edge porn
I need to get get the bishop out
somewhere and I can he can still opt for
a long castling relief I know it goes
back okay well maybe 95 is a move this
is really possible but here it might be
now I just placed the Queen again okay I
should take now before he castles long
and after such a capture can recapture
with the rook
that is not that's not a good position
- Utley should have done something more
conventional 95 - still looks like an
issue to me but he doesn't play it I
came now I probably have to stop me five
white is just better him I have I don't
have a clear safe place for my king
may this night be six to see for amongst
others going to yeah I think I can apply
at him it's no immediate drawback
we are still jumping there on you don't
see why not
I'm also not unhappy if I'm trading some
pieces they move like 92 for example
okay after have to evacuate here
Bishop to f6 maybe if that is that is a
good move
I should take note of that okay that
didn't occur to me at all and it makes
perfect sense of course Wow
Wow
[Music]
completely busted him
I like completely busted night takes is
just very strong neck we take c4 wind
Sun they would completely apply move I
know it sounds wacky if anyway it's got
1990 word you just totally outplay me
Quincy for is just winning and you find
it of course M
what a game got 1,800 in palladium 1800
name just played a good game you know I
can I do I played to creatively and I
know that's right rhodium it's too
simple just to simply it's got
absolutely no problem to solve
I totally I totally did not register
that he has a form I can I should resign
maybe I still still have a hard time to
accept that I'm losing this one
threatening mate
what never resign never resign
I'm a little bit stunned yeah well it
completely killed me you just killed me
yeah so at age five no I shouldn't do
that I mean I don't think that this f4
g3 mixture is it's too great to be
honest but I should play normal moves
against it and this is not good
it just stitches two to fancy b5 yeah I
actually felt I was okay again when we
when we got here and I got this got this
Knight to c4 I felt it's not too bad I
guess is a for the whole time I had
simply did not have this on the radar
like here and a four I'm just totally
killed
I just totally kill them so night a four
is suggested by the comp
and it's just not good yeah just not
good and here yeah I shouldn't I should
blunder the piece but I mean the
position is just totally totally over
night before takes I'm a little bit
surprised okay King p8 yeah you have to
do it problem with this I even
overlooked wincy form and you just
totally totally lost
yeah well yeah he did a good conversion
job can take pawn second t5 and so on
which I mean it's nothing just nothing
going on here just anything group should
one or something yeah there was
obviously extremely lucky so I shouldn't
go h5 you know it I had I had played
this in an earlier game when a white
head castle short that obviously makes a
big difference
and he is probably just a ridiculous
idea okay guys thanks for watching